البدايه من تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
بعد تنفيذ سلاح البحريه الروسيه اليوم
مناورات صاروخيه على اهداف بالبحر الاسود
في المقابل اوكرانيا اتهمت الاسطوله
الروسي بالتصعيد في البحر الاسود مع
استمرار قصف ميناء وداس الاستراتيجي من
جهته قال الرئيس الروسي انه لا اثر للهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد معتبرا ان الغرب يشعر
بخيبه امل من كييف من موسكو تنضم الينا
مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي ومنكياف مراسل
الجزيره عمر الحاج والبدايه مع كيرانيا من
مواقف بوتين اليوم امام مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي
نعم يمكن القول حسن ان رئيس الروسي وفي
مجمل يعني تصريحاته الصادره لهذا اليوم
يعني
تصبها وتصب جلها في اتجاه ان ما يجري
حاليا على الارض اوكرانيا ياتي وفقا لما
كانت تريده روسيا على الاقل حتى هذه
اللحظه اشار الرئيس لوسيل فلاديمير بوتين
الى انه لان كل الدعم العسكري الذي تحصله
الى جانب المساعده والدعم العسكري من قبل
الالاف من المرتزقه والمستشارين العسكريين
كل ذلك لم يحقق اي نادي من اي نتائج
الهجوم العسكريه الاوكرانيين مضاد لم يحقق
اي نتائج بل على العكس فان قدرات الجانب
الاوكراني من ناحيه التعبئه يعني تنفذ
شيئا فشيئا فضلا عن ذلك يعني تحدث بوتين
عن ان القوات الاوكرانيه تتكبد خسائر
بعشرات تقدر بعشرات الالاف من
من القوات وايضا في اطار التسليح تحدث
بوتين عن نقطه غايه الاهميه لان حتى دول
الحلف الناتو تستيقظ حاليا اسلحتها وان
مجمعها العسكري قدراته الانتاجيه لا تسمح
بتعويض هذه الاسلحه اذا هناك اشاره من قبل
بوتين الى ان كل ما يجري يصب في صالح
روسيا نقطه في غايه الاهميه تحدث عنه فيما
يتعلق بالحراك الاوكراني البولندي
الليتواني بالقرب من الحدود
البيلاروسيه حدث واشار لنا فكره او حديث
هذه الدول عن عزمها انشاء وحده عسكريه
مشتركه هدفه بالدرجه الاولى السيطره على
جزء من الاراضي الاوكرانيه بالاشاره
للاراضي الغربيه ومنطقه الهوف وفي هذا
السياق لم يستبعد كوتي الامكانيه ان تتدخل
بولندا عسكريا في النزاع على الارض في
اوكرانيا وقد اعطى الاوامر لي
تحركات السلطات البولنديه عن كثب في هذا
الاطار شدد بوتين ووجه انذارات واضحه
للدول الغربيه لا سيما لهذه الدول ايضا
مفادها انه في حال يعني تعرضت بيلاروسيا
بيلاروسيا المتاخمه لبولندا لاي اعتداء
فان روسيا ستعتبر ذلك اعتداء على اراضيها
وستقوم باستخدام كل السبل المتاحه لديها
للرد على هذا الاعتداء
شكرا لك رانيا معنا لنتحول الى عمر الحاج
في كيان عمر مجموعه مواقف اوكرانيه اليوم
كان منها ما يحصل في الجنوب في حوض البحر
الاسود تحديدا او تلك المتعلقه
باتفاق الحبوب والسفن الناقله للحبوب
نعم حسن قبل ان اجيبك على هذا السؤال دعني
ابدا بهذه التصريحات التي جاء وردت قبل
قليل على لساني المتحدث باسم استخبارات
العسكريه في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
اندريه الذي قال ان بلاده لا تستبعد ان
تشهد محاوله تمرد اخرى جديده في روسيا
خلال الايام القادمه وقال ان الاستخبارات
لديها معلومات تفيد بمثل هذا التحرك
المحتمل وعاد ذلك الى سخط في بعض طبقات
جنرالات الجيش اضافه الى النخبه السياسيه
التي لا ترى جدوى في ضم القرم من جهه
وايضا شن الهجوم الكامل على اوكرانيا من
جهه اخرى هذه المعلومات المقتضبه الذي
التي وردت قبل قليل كان جديره بالاشاره
اليها اما بالنسبه لسؤالك فان الريزنسكي
يتحدث اليوم انه اجتمع مع قاده الجيش
وقاده البحريه
واقروا مجموعه من الاجراءات التي من شانها
التسهيل في مواصله عمليه نقل الحبوب بعيدا
عن الان الروسي من هذه المبادره وقال ايضا
ان القوات الروسيه استهدفت بشكل متعمد
الكثير من مشات البنيه التحتيه والموانئ
التي خصصت لاتمام هذه الاتفاقيه في شاطئ
الاتفاقيه الحبوب المبرمه في وقت سابق من
العام الماضي ايضا عاده اوكرانيا للتجديد
مرتجديد موقفها مره اخرى من اعتبارها كل
السفن التي ستنقل الحبوب الى الموانئ
الروسيه في البحر الاسود او الموانئ
الاوكرانيه التي تقع تحت سيطره القوات
الروسيه
اهدافا عسكريه وانها ستتعامل معها في بيان
سابق قالت اوكرانيا
حاله اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه الى مصيري
الطراد موسكو في اشاره الى انها تملك
بالفعل القدره على استهداف هذه السفن هذا
الموقف الذي جدد اليوم على لسان ميكائيل
وبدلياك المستشار في مكتب الرئتين في
المكتب الرئاسي قال ان اوكرانيا جاده في
هذا في هذا الاستهداف وفي اخذ في اعتبار
هذه السفن تهديدا واهدافا عسكريه
وقال مره اخرى ان كل التوتر الذي نشهده في
البحر الاسود هو نتيجه لتصرفات اسطول
الاسطول الروسي في البحر الذي يستهدف
المنشاءات الحيويه وايضا يتعمد استهداف
مدينه اوديسا ومدينه خلال الايام الماضيه
شكرا لكم عمر الحاج من كييف وشكرا لرانيا
دريدي كانت معنا من موسكو